dicker hier ist 50
ihr fragt euch wahrscheinlich ey Luca
warum blockst du schon wieder gar keinen
Bock da drauf er steht tatsächlich was
an in meinem Leben so Abwechslung mal
und zwar ist Jeremy Frey Grant zu Gast
unseres Podcasts falls nicht kennt hier
ein paar tiktok Ausschnitte von ihm
Jeremy one
and the champion and the best
[Musik]
ihr seid live von meinem tiktok drauf 5
Uhr
[Musik]
let's
i'm the number one and the champion
[Musik]
ich hole Jeremy fragrance gerade vom
Hauptbahnhof Köln ab sein Zug ist um
11:15 Uhr angekommen es ist 11:25 Uhr
ich habe mir die Ausrede einfallen
lassen dass sie irgendwo eine Demo hier
in Köln ist verdammt hier sieht weißt du
dass das gelogen war sorry Jeremy war
eine Notlüge ich musste über krank
kacken nur wenige Minuten später
[Musik]
ja turns out Jeremy ist glaube ich
selber noch nicht da etwas länger als
nur wenige Minuten später hey Leute ich
bin hier mit dem Luca und positiv
überrascht im Sinne von erst total
gebildet und auch unternehmerisch am
Start Linie also er ist auch anscheinend
einer der wenigen die es verstehen zum
einen rational und zum anderen
künstlerisch zu sein weil die meisten
sind ja eher so Johnny Depp hier ich
sauf mich voll und bin der lustige
artist aber haben dann verlieren dann
die Kontrolle über das logische
miteinander zu kommunizieren und das war
doch mal der Donald Trump über den Tommy
Hilfiger gesagt nee über den über den
Calvin Klein ist der Calvin Klein das
auch so geil drauf hat
naja wenn man das so ein bisschen
trennen kann und wir lernen uns ja
gerade so ein bisschen kennen
dann ist das sehr smart kann ich euch
nur empfehlen ich poste hier wie wir uns
gesehen haben
Germany
speak English and
video
die Deutschen kennen ihn das ist der
Luca mit seinem geilen Porsche wir sind
hier where and Cologne and we are about
to Shooter little Podcast witch Dragons
is do you usually wear welche Düfte
normalerweise bacara Rouge gerade nicht
äh right now rosa eniper oh crazy man
Kölner junge Leute
wir nehmen jetzt den Podcast Folge auf
und ihr seht es schon mal einen kurzen
Ausschnitt wer hat uns gefunden nur so
kurz unterhalten uns dann aufgefallen
wenn wir uns jetzt noch länger
unterhalten ist glaube ich blöd von
Podcast und ein bisschen aber du warst
geiler Typ Alter wir haben jetzt gerade
Podcast aufgenommen da Sandra Jeremy
danke nochmal dass du am scharf was
willst du noch irgendwas sagen in meinem
Blog irgendwie ja also Lavi er Bell
trägt sie er trägt Roger Dorf Ingmar er
trägt ein u-duft und ich gar keinen aber
naja ich trage sechs Düfte auf meinen
Armen um festzustellen wie lange die
halten weil das potenzielle neue
Releases sind und so bin ich weniger
disstracted wenn ich hier hatte erst
noch drauf und der andere nicht mehr und
so nach dem Motto deswegen trage ich
persönlich gerade keinen Duft an mir
aber schon an meinen Armen
golden Rolex red Ferrari Jeremy Fraggles
hasse egal halt einfach nicht mein
Lebensmotto
gesehen die Folge ist vorbei was sagt da
[Musik]
AUA wir nehmen jetzt tatsächlich noch
eine weitere Folge auf um das ganze mal
so ein bisschen Revue passieren zu
lassen und er hat mir tatsächlich auch
noch eine Pastinake geschenkt der Liebe
Jeremy danke dafür aus Paris für mich
mitgenommen hat er gesagt
man denkt wir leben im Drogenkartell
hier mittendrin alles bestrate dreh dich
mal und zeig deine Tür die Tür ja
[Musik]
das war gerade unangenehm ja war so sind
wir im Leben hallo kennen mich aus dem
Playboy glaube ich falls euch übrigens
fragt warum Sandra die ganze Zeit zum
humpeln ist ich habe mich mitten auf den
Ring übelst gemault ich glaube man hat
meine ganze hast du gesehen ja sandra
hat tatsächlich ein Bänderriss glaube
ich und ja wir zeigen euch jetzt heute
mal einfach so ein bisschen Köln die
Podcast Folge ist vorbei wir sind gerade
in Belgischen Viertel es ist
Herbststimmung und meine Freunde meine
Freunde sind natürlich auch hier mit
dabei meine Freunde ja und wir gehen
jetzt auf jeden Fall was frühstücken
meine Damen und Herren kauft alle mit
dem Code Sandra meine Sachen bei Ocean
Party haben wir auch schon direkt ein
Stativ kann er einfach mal die Kamera
auf dem Smart drauflegen erstmal ein
bisschen Deppen damit es noch
unangenehmer wird hier alles so peinlich
war noch nicht heute festgehalten wir
müssen ein bisschen mehr so wie Jeremy
Fraggles aus uns rauskommen aber ich
kann das nicht ich kann nicht filmen
wenn Leute so kommen weißt du guck mal
zweimal Sandra dreimal viermal
ich habe auch ein Podcast der nennt sich
Baby gab Business da geht es um Social
Media Marketing karrieregeschichten
genauso wie bei uns oder
[Musik]
[Applaus]
stell die brennenden Haare
neue so feiern
hallo meine Lieben
wow what the day guys
spaß beiseite Freunde es war wirklich
ein
unfassbar witziger Tag heute die Podcast
Folge geht heute um Mitternacht online
immer von Mittwoch auf Donnerstag in der
Nacht ihr wisst Bescheid Spotify Dick
und Doof ich kann jetzt gerade no job
noch nicht so ganz einschätzen ob ihr
Jeremy Fraggles ausgefeiert wie Sandra
und ich aber sammle ich am dummen Humor
und wir feiern deine tiktoks übertrieben
sein extrem extrovertiertes Verhalten
sein generell lustiges auftreten und so
ist einfach Wahnsinn und wir dachten es
passt ganz gut für den Podcast ich habe
alle von euch die sich die Folge nachher
komplett anschauen werden oder anhören
werden auf Spotify die werden sich auch
denken oh irgendwie anders die Folge
aber es war ein sehr sehr sehr sehr sehr
sehr witziger Tag ich hoffe euch hat
dieser Vlog hier auch gefallen denn ich
werde den Block an der Stelle jetzt auch
beenden es ist zwar noch mehr oder
weniger Held draußen ich habe gerade ein
bisschen geschnitten noch mich auf
andere Sachen gekümmert andere Themen
bis es Power Hassel jetzt habe ich mir
hier gerade noch so unser kleines Curry
gekocht Reis Kartoffeln ein bisschen
Currysauce alles mögliche an Gemüse
reingeschnibbelt weil ich ja aktuell
auch so ein bisschen sauber Oktober
mache ich trinke keinen Alkohol ich
versuche auf meine Ernährung zu achten
ich versuche zuzunehmen power
wenn euch dieser Block hier gefallen hat
dann lasst gerne einen Daumen hoch unter
dem Video hier da abonniert meinen Kanal
und
klickt oh ist das heißt auf die Glocke
um weitere Videos nicht zu verpassen
Jeremies und in der Beschreibung
verlinkt der Podcasts und in der
Beschreibung verlinkt und ich
ja erst jetzt